hello everyone and a special welcome
back to all you heroic horses chameleon
confidants and some loving snowmen out
there and you are
this is versus i'm your host mark ellis
and today on the show i have the
dastardly deed of deciding a duo of
disney delights as in which film will
reign supreme frozen or tangled yep i'm
the same simpleton that's taking you
through episodes such as arnold versus
stallone robocop versus terminator and
tango versus cash and now i'm putting
all of the chips into the center of the
disney classic animation table will ana
and elsa chill tangled's hopes or will
rapunzel and flynn climb their way to
victory and full disclosure we haven't
actually done a tango versus cash
episode yet but i'm pitching it for next
season as for these two animated
blockbusters from the 2010s it should be
quite the competition in one corner you
have frozen the uber's successful
franchise launching first film that
thrives on the bond of sisterhood the
rivalry of siblings and a snowman who
isn't sure he loves winter in the other
corner is tangled the tale of rapunzel
that features a villainous mother type a
charming rogue hero and the strongest
hair follicles this side of andre agassi
i'm gonna tell him don't you dare wait
that was a wig
okay well uh poison lead singer brett
michael's hair somebody's gotta tell him
get out of town that's fake too all
right look as my world collapses around
me let's just look at how we'll
determine a winner round one box office
round two tomato meter slash audience
score round three characters round four
music and then we'll do a wild card
round that pascal the wonder chameleon
hopes is all about acting range i could
actually do a whole episode just based
on sven vs maximus but they will get
their time to shine later and as much as
i love doing a fun intro to get everyone
loose before battle eventually we do
have to start this fracas which means
one film will take the crown of the best
disney flick of the decade and the other
will have to let it go
see i got out of the way early now we
can relax and enjoy the princess rumble
let's get it on round one box office in
breaking news animated disney films tend
to do okay at the movie theaters and
that's only when they're not smashing
every box office record known to
humanity anytime mickey releases a new
drawn picture a billion dollar haul is
in play and for one of these two flicks
became a reality yep twas frozen that
set worldwide records
[Applause]
but tangled came first the 2010 flick
based on the story of rapunzel and her
ladder-like locks crushed at the
multiplex combing almost 600 million
dollars at the worldwide box office
that's certainly a fresh-smelling scent
but the profit margin wasn't quite as
lucrative the movie and its frontier
shattering animated technological
advances proved costly and the final
budget has been estimated to be around
260 million dollars that is really
that's unfortunate it was a risky
investment but it did end up making
folks rich by comparison frozen only
costs 150 million dollars to make
only 150 mil how much did steamboat will
he cost all you needed back in the day
was a pen and a sticky notepad the times
they are changing sorcery
i knew there was something dubious going
on here but don't fret studio heads
frozen did just fine if by fine you mean
1.28 billion dollars across the globe
that smashed the previous record held by
an animated film which had belonged to
buzz woody and a very sinister teddy
bear it also became the highest earner
in the history of the musical genre and
the top grosser of any female directed
film ever and for that one moment
everything was perfect pop that
champagne but chug it quick and then
that moment ended records were meant to
be broken and frozen no longer has those
records that's the bad news the great
news is we're keeping it in the family
frozen two broke its older sister's
marks and still holds them to this day
currently frozen one is either number
two or three on the all-time animated
box office list it really just depends
on whether you count the 2019 lion king
as animation i mean didn't they actually
have like one shot of a real thing there
but then we had that weird moment
halfway through the movie where the
miracle of giraffe digestion kicks off
the circle of life and now my head hurts
again i don't understand you when you
talk like that the bottom line is frozen
made a crap ton of money the ron frozen
had at the theaters is just as
impressive it started out sprinting with
a 93 million dollar opening weekend but
then marathoned its way through the
winter grossing at least 2 million bucks
every weekend from november 27th all the
way until march 16th anytime you can
rake in cash from thanksgiving to st
patrick's day you're doing something
right and now adding to frozen's
portfolio is its highest honor yet you
win round one
how about two out of three i love
tangled but it didn't even make half of
its opponent's return even though it
cost more cheddar to make now if i had
to levy an argument i might point out
that tangled's production process
definitely helped curtail the spending
on frozen a few years later you know how
i feel about the mummy blah blah blah
blah is very annoying i'm just teasing
you're adorable i love you so much
darling but come on money talks and a
billion bucks shouts and frozen gets on
the board first it's one to nothing
patience boys
all good things to those who wait
round two tomato meter slash audience
score not only did frozen dominate
multiple seasons at the multiplex but
people went cray-cray for it if you're
still a top-selling kid's backpack lunch
box or tricycle chances are you're also
beloved is quality cinema but tangled
open to rave reviews and shuttle disney
into a new dawn where technology met
modern storytelling spoiler alert both
flicks are super certified fresh frozen
is at 90 on the tomato meter and tangled
is nipping on its icy heels at 89
percent and although it did shatter toy
story 3's cash record the sequel to
frozen couldn't match that franchise's
staying power with the critics frozen 2
is still fresh but it's 78
and since we're sticking with just the
originals today until we get that
tangled sequel which i've been patiently
awaiting i know you're reading my
letters goofy how's about a deeper look
into the audience score it's just about
as close as they come yet again except
this time it's tangled who seizes the
upper hand earning 87 of the audience's
love compared to 85 for frozen oh boy
why do i get the feeling every round
from here on out is going to be this
close and now for some quick math i
usually don't do stunts on the show but
if we combine the percentages of each
flick it makes just a one percent
difference and it's tangle that comes
out on top 176 percent to 175 percent
for frozen as opposed to every
professional athlete ever who only gives
110
it's like they're not even trying since
i still have plenty of time to kill in
this round i'll point out what i just
learned there's actually more tangled
adventures to enjoy we're still waiting
on a proper feature film sequel but
rapunzel's tangled adventures ran for
multiple seasons and saw the return of
stars mandy moore and zachary levi and
they're probably watching this show
right now hey gang i love a walk to
remember and i was on the chuck train
from day one by the slimmest of margins
as in one whole percentage point i'm
giving the round to zach mandy and
tangled team hairbrush gets on the board
and ties things up one to one oh
somebody got me a glass because i just
found me a tall drink of water round
three characters well that certainly was
a breezy round which gives us more time
to thaw out my feelings for the primary
tertiary and tetra-tertiary characters
in this phase
what sure we love the leads of these
respective flicks but i'm also going to
scrutinize the adorable animal sidekicks
the conniving villains and the sentient
snow
do we have an origin story for oauth as
canon yet i bet he's from buffalo new
york i don't have a skull
or bones but before we get to those
adorable sidekicks the wonderful
princesses or the dudes who hope to one
day take one of them princesses to the
olive garden let's break bad with some
antagonistic energy submitting for your
consideration hans the ostensible
villain in frozen voiced by veteran
stage performer santino fontana he
shares some qualities with mother gothel
the tangled nemesis played by another
stage great donna murphy they're both
actual 3d characters as opposed to a
decidedly one note baddie like we've
seen in some previous decades of disney
storytelling
[Music]
hans does have some redeeming qualities
and seems to genuinely care about being
a good leader even if that meant
completely lying to anna to get there oh
meanwhile the relationship between mama
g and rapunzel feels even more
emotionally complex she clearly harbors
some affection for rappy can i even call
her rappy rap z and there is evidence of
a circle of protection over the child
that she kidnapped and locked away in a
tower oh
great
now i'm the bad guy but it's just
because g wants to stay young and
vibrant and come on don't we all
cryotherapy and botox may not have been
available in these times so you may have
to consider more extreme measures to
maintain that youthful glow as for the
princesses themselves the sibling
rivalry of elsa and anna should feel
very familiar to anyone who grew up with
a bro or a sis at any given moment of my
own upbringing i could point to who
amongst us three kids was displaying
personality traits of either weed
character although if you were just to
look at me as a child you'd assume i was
more of an olaf what can i say
whatchamacallit bars are delicious
elsa's guilt and her stunning ability to
keep her emotions about her life choices
at bay make her one of the more tortured
and introspective folks in all of disney
history and anna's relentless belief
that good can prevail acts as a nice
foil there's also lots of potential
therapy topics boiling just below the
surface for rapunzel who is far from a
locked up damsel in distress
sure she'd love to find a partner and
forge a freer life for herself but her
plucky optimism resourcefulness and
feisty nature are a clear message to the
audience that she doesn't need saving
which is good news because flynn rider
is likely more bark than bite oh come on
he fancies himself the hero of his own
story but he's less about brawn and bold
and more about charm and goofiness which
is a refreshing update from past
generations of more alpha prince
charmings that roll out of bed save the
day then live happily ever after zachary
levi's natural sense of humor and easy
manner add the perfect spice to mandy
moore's grounded dreamer rapunzel but
can we now please talk about pascal and
maximus the real heroes of that movie
pascal could have been a jason bourne
level spy or an antonia banderas styled
assassin does no one remember that movie
it was antonio and stallone and julianne
moore and they played assassins
what was the name of that movie anyway
he was also an x versus sever point is
pascal can be center stage when it
behooves rapunzel but his ability to
camout any time makes for a useful and
humorous sidekick and then we have
maximus and along with him comes a
scalding hot take from me i root for him
more than the other maximus yeah that
one entertained me just fine but disney
horses have a long lineage of bringing
levity to a flick max adds even more the
dude is basically a dog in a horse's
body and that makes him the perfect
wookie companion to flynn's han solo and
then maybe rapunzel's princess leia and
look at that i still kept all those
metaphors in the disney family well i've
gotta say didn't know you had that in
you back there that was pretty
impressive olaf the snowman was a hit
right out of the gate and i gotta
imagine that's why absolutely no one
showed up to the theater to see the
snowman mr policeman you should have
just not made the movie we don't want
anything bad happening to anything made
out of snow yet olaf's obsession with
warmer climate provides a much needed
lighter subplot to frozen's main focus
sven has some dog qualities and some
solid laughs as well he's no maximus but
i guess he'd make a solid proxima we're
spoiled with more modern
characterizations of classic storybook
tropes in both of these films and it's a
lead reason why both movies were so
successful but as endearing as anna and
elsa are they might have their own movie
stolen by a talking glob of snow and i
love olaf but tangled feels more
balanced between the characters and the
sidekicks enhance the main plotline of
rapunzel's yearning for freedom and
companionship in that order and while
hans is a solid villain whose motives
aren't just reductionist decepticon
there more than meets the eye but mother
gothel belongs in the pantheon of all
time great disney villains yes i said it
evil enough to warrant being on that
list but deep enough to make us consider
her view of the world as well it's not
an easy task you know what i see
i see a strong confident beautiful young
lady
oh look you're here too
and neither was judging this round but
i'm giving the point to my guy maximus
and whoever else was in that long-haired
movie tangled scores the point and
surges ahead of frozen two to one round
four music
well frozen had the early lead but since
then they've
let it go but elsa anna and company have
a good shot in this round and it's going
to feature my musical appreciation
towards both soundtracks maybe we'll
pull in some data as well but remember
numbers are fun statistics are
informative but the winner of this round
will be whichever film's music makes my
heart soar believe in true love and hope
that peace will reign over conflict well
he was sprightly
especially for a man in heels or i'll
just pick whichever movie's best song my
niece is singing this week the legend
alan menken did the music for tangled
and it was slightly different than some
of his previous efforts films within the
disney empire like hercules as well as
other works featured menken working in
his wheelhouse which would incorporate a
decidedly rock influence style but for
tangled he's been quoted as saying it
was his most pop oriented fun fact the
great tune when will my life begin was
originally going to be a song called
what more could i ever need and was to
feature a much more positive outlook on
being held captive in a tower with some
luxurious amenities and while that may
have suited me just fine i'm the kind of
fellow who could live in a hotel for
years as long as there's a gym netflix
and that fancy lobby water with the
random fruits in it delicious i love it
even more but i get that not everyone is
as simple as me and some people like
rapunzel might want to dream outside of
the confines of their current situation
no amounts of confining could contain
the runaway success of the frozen music
so let's talk about just how great let
it go is i don't
care
what they're going to say
originally elsa was going to be more of
a one note character but the evolution
of this tune helped deepen her own
emotional journey written by robert and
kristen anderson lopez both saw this as
an opportunity to get more than surface
level with elsa kristin thought the song
would be a perfect conduit to describe
the intense pressure and scrutiny that
women go through on so many levels on a
daily basis and robert wanted the number
to reflect the feeling of being a
straight a student then suddenly failing
a test where do you go from here but the
star of letico is obviously the soaring
vocals by adina menzel the tony award
winner who is on the original wicket on
broadway is such a singular talent that
not only did her tracks elevate the film
the soundtrack for frozen became a
worldwide sensation moving more than 3
million copies the cassette tape cd mp3
or 8-track became the top-selling album
of 2014 and may have been that rare case
when the music helped keep getting
people back to the theater to see frozen
again and again demi lovato added a more
top 40 version of let it go and other
hits like for the first time in forever
and do you want to build a snowman
cement this album is anything but a
one-hit wonder the tangled soundtrack
also performed admirably hitting the
billboard top 200 charts with a peak at
number 44 it was also the seventh
best-selling soundtrack of the year and
rose to number three on the kids chart
but even with mandy moore and others
belting out quality tunes like i've got
a dream and i see the light the darkness
cast by frozen shadow is quite large
even though it may be permanently lodged
in the heads of millions of parents
around the world it was like my whole
life got turned upside down the frozen
soundtrack combines irresistible songs
with a pop sensibility that makes the
perfect engine to tell that story
tangled works is a full-on musical
production as well but the tunes weren't
quite as memorable as the disney
phenomenon that would follow three years
later so while i can thank tangled for
never getting a song stuck in my head
for weeks on end i have to award frozen
the point for a monumental musical
achievement team sub zero wins the round
and we're tied to a piece and now it's
time for the wild card round legacy
it all comes down to this the wild card
that will determine the match is the
same round that will examine the lasting
impact of these two feuding films don't
worry they'll be friends again after
this competition and will no doubt laugh
about this when they're hanging out with
the other disney princesses from ralph
breaks the internet that's seriously one
of my favorite scenes in any movie ever
as we mentioned already frozen looms
large over just about any other animated
film simply because of its amazing level
of success over a billion dollars earned
three million records sold and an untold
number of little tikes getting into ice
skating will testify to that claim and
while the success of tangled was also
substantial it was nowhere near hot
enough to help thaw the icy crypt that
frozen has held over all other animated
fare this century but the lasting impact
of a movie isn't just tied to its
financial success or catchy tunes if
tangled wasn't a complete revolution in
terms of classic style animation
technology it was at least a giant leap
for cartoon kind so yes that beefy 260
million dollar budget did pay off
tangled pioneered a more perfect
blending of drawn and cgi interplay and
the results were stunning just look at
that now iconic lantern sequence or any
shot we're lucky enough to get of
rapunzel's flowing locks it looks like
real hair and much more real than a
certain tennis player or a certain hair
metal front man that i just found out
about cannot believe i fell for it like
a chicken with the face of a monkey
frozen cost less to make and did much
better the box office but that was no
doubt taking a cue from tangled's
meticulous production process where
frozen does have the upper hand in this
stage is the instantly recognizable song
power and the sisterly conflict that
took a very different turn than lifelong
disney fans might have expected despite
the fun of spen and the quick jokes from
oauth the plotline gets dark at points
and echoes the emotional impact of
turning point scenes from films like
beauty and the beast and the lion king
but whereas the full picture of frozen
can't quite live up to those all-time
great predecessors tangled is blissfully
unaware that some dope on a show called
versus would ever be judging it it just
has a blast from start to finish giving
an updated brush to rapunzel's
mythological locks the movie is quick
smart and deceivingly deep in its themes
of longing risk-taking and the
consequences of an overbearing parent
while gothel is neither an absentee
mother figure and she's definitely not
the cool mom who wants the kids to drink
chardonnay at my house she does possess
more introspection than the surface
level of villains before like maleficent
well until they made her backstory and
then she became sympathetic cruella
deville now they made her backstory and
now she's sympathetic okay job of the
hunt it's a one note vile gangster eats
frogs hopefully not pascal because he's
a chameleon whereas frozen feels long in
the tooth by the end though nonetheless
enjoyable tangled breezes through its
run time and leaves the perfect
combination of fulfilling us without
over serving it's an interesting
dichotomy because frozen's run time is
one hour 42 minutes only two minutes
longer than tangled my heart wants to
vote for tangled here because i do find
it a better disney flick and more
rewatchable but frozen's legacy isn't
just tied to one film it had an even
more blockbustery sequel and beloved
olaf has spun off numerous pieces of
content that i dare say were more widely
seen than anything else in the tangled
universe you're way overthinking this
trust me and as great as tangled is it
works just fine as a standalone film
frozen feels like a bigger world in
which we can continue to have adventures
that might just happen to rack up a cool
billion bucks on the big screen tangled
gave frozen all it could handle in this
matchup but at the end of the day from
these two beloved films a winner must
emerge and elsa and anna have earned the
win in the legacy round and thus the
match today
i fully accept that this decision will
alienate me from maximus and pascal who
likely has already blended into the wall
so i can't even apologize to the poor
guy
and that's how it goes here at versus i
walked into this matchup expecting to
have some fun celebrating two modern
disney classics but i'll be darned if
this grinch didn't grow a heart and
remember how much i love mandy moore not
enough for me to check out this is us
but you know a walk to remember still
rocks and now it's your turn dear viewer
frozen winning is just my opinion and i
was rooting for tangle he's go crazy
but disney makes films designed to be
enjoyed by all so give me your take hit
me up on social media at mark ellis live
and head over to rottentomatoes.com for
a slew of deep dives into the best
animated films of the 2000s thanks for
watching versus i'm mark ellis and as
olaf would say i'm like a baby unicorn
[Music]
[Music]
you